Hello everybody!
Hello hello!
Oh my gosh.
There was like, there's so many like life updates I wanted to give you guys today.
There's so many things going on.
Every day... okay it's like before stream, work.
After stream, work.
It has not calmed down at all yet.
It's like oh my god.
There's just, I wish I could like leak but I can't because contracts.
It's just, oh I'm so excited.
The next couple of months is gonna be like, there's just so many things packed up the next couple of months.
Let's just say, I can say this.
I'll say this.
Let's just say the Doki Bird World Tour.
Let's just say, there's a lot of conventions lined up.
So, there's like one of these things that's been like on the, like on the back burner.
Like not back burner but there's been like a lot of things regarding like convention wise.
Because I feel like I can say stuff like that because it's not just like you know, it's not one convention.
There's like multiple conventions that's like in the works.
And I feel like I can say stuff like that because it's not just like you know, it's not one convention.
And that's like one of the things that I've always like you know, I really, really, really wanted to like meet you guys.
I really want to meet my dragoons.
And you know like, I never had the chance.
I mean I did have some chances.
But you know, there was like one instance where I, you know, it wasn't my choice.
Where like, I wasn't able to meet you guys last time.
And so like, this is like one of the things I was pushing for.
Especially when I never got a chance to meet like Canadian goons as well.
Canadian dragoons as well as like for like conventions in Canada.
I wasn't able to do like any, I wasn't fortunate enough to have like an experience to do like a convention in Canada.
Or like being able to do like more worldwide conventions and stuff like that.
So there's, I'll just say like you know, the Doki Bird World Tour.
Could be a reality.
It's actually crazy.
Okay, I didn't, okay same with like for those who don't know.
For those who, okay for those who don't know and don't follow me on Twitter.
There was like stuff like, guys, Medi, I'm getting my passport immediate.
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Medi, it's not just Canada.
It's a world tour.
It's, it's a, it's a world tour.
That means I would be in various places in the world.
I might even be in America.
You don't need to get a passport.
Like...
So one of the things I've always wanted was to be able to meet like dragoons around the world.
And I was, lately I haven't been fortunate enough to sort of have, you know, a little sort of be able to do that.
So, um, hey friend, thank you for the one, uh, one ship.
Give this ship.
Thank you.
Um, and, uh, and I'm trying to like, try not to say too many things to get in, I'm trying not to get in trouble right now chat.
So I'm trying to like limit what I can say and what I can't say.
But like, uh, some of you guys weren't following me on Twitter.
Uh, uh, I be power.
I have a power.
And Hyatt sent me a PC.
Remember when I kept telling you guys, you guys were like, Doki, please, buy a new PC, Doki.
For the love of God, you keep crashing.
By the way, I'm still have, uh, by the way, I'm still using my old PC still.
But anyway, they're like, please.
And I'm like, I, I, I know guys.
It's just that there is a PC that's sort of stuck in Canadian customs right now.
And finally, it's finally unstuck.
It's been stuck in Canadian, I swear.
It's been stuck in Canadian customs for like about two weeks now.
Like, like, like, it's been stuck for like maybe like two to three weeks in Canadian customs.
Because, uh, I don't know.
I don't know why, but it's been stuck there for a very long time.
But today, well technically like, yeah, today we sort of like got the PC finally.
Um, after we sorted it out with everything.
But it was actually, it was, I wouldn't say it's like actually insane.
Because like, I didn't realize this.
I thought it was just unmarketable.
Like, I legitimately thought, I legitimately thought I was just, you know, I saved my mind too much.
Or like, I'm just unmarketable.
I'm not cute enough.
Or like, I'm not the cute anime girl that like, that fits the mold.
Or like, I thought I was like just unmarketable.
And like, I was like, oh, I didn't try hard enough.
But like, it's actually crazy.
But there's been so many like sponsors.
And so many like conventions that have like reached out to me.
And was like, we've always wanted to work with you.
And like, and I'm like, really?
Me?
I thought, I thought I was just unmarketable.
I didn't.
They're like, we've always wanted to work with you, Doki.
And like, it's crazy.
There were so many.
And I was like, me?
I was so surprised.
Especially conventions.
I was like, wait, what?
Really?
You wanted me to be there?
I'm like, and then like, okay, cause so like, they need, you need to charge.
Like we charge, when you're doing appearance fees.
We charge like, you have to charge yourself for appearance fees.
You know, you obviously can't do it for free.
Because how the fuck am I gonna survive?
And so like, so.
So like, they're like, how much is your appearance fees for like conventions?
And I was like, oh, it's this much.
Is it too expensive?
I hope it's enough.
Like, I was like, I hope it's not too expensive.
I was told by my, I was told by my manager that this is like, that should be like the general range for appearance fees.
And then, and then like one of my friends who's, who's one of my friends who does like, convention stuff.
She was like, telling me, she was scolding me and was like, your appearance fees are too cheap.
And I was like, I don't know.
I
don't know what I'm doing.
Cause I've never done stuff.
And then my friend was like, you're too cheap.
What the fuck?
Like, you need to charge more for your appearance fees.
They all want you right now.
You need to charge more.
You're way too cheap.
And I'm like, I don't know.
I was like, I just, I just want to, I just wanted to go to conventions and like meet dragons.
I don't know what my price is.
So yeah, I'm like every day, every day I'm like, oh no, don't worry.
I'm it's us dollars.
Cause I was like, bro, the us dollar right now is so fucking good at the moment compared to like any other country.
I saw this thing.
I was so sad.
I was like so sad because like, I don't even, I saw the Twitter post, but I don't remember which Japanese Twitter was, but there was like a Japanese Twitter that was like, try and be like, it was, that was like, oh please, please buy our stuff, like on Twitter.
Because apparently the yen is so bad right now that they're trying to get like Americans to like buy stuff in their store because of how bad the yen was.
Cause it's crashing apparently.
And they're like, please...
Please use the US dollar right now.
It's like because it's just a lot US dollars like really really good at the moment And so they're like asking people in the States to order stuff in Japan just because of how bad the yen is Yeah, it's actually crazy So that's why I like wonder like you want to want us to pay the appearance fee in US dollars or Canadian dollars?
I would like US
I'm just like US dollars, please no matter what US dollars Because I have a US bank like I want my bank accounts accepts US dollars because I have separate US and Canadian So like I'm like if the Canadian dollar crashes at least like, you know, I can just convert my US dollars to Canadian
Because Even , you know, even the Canadian dollar is pretty fucking garbage right now.
So I'm just like yeah, I would US please
AP thank you the super chat.
Thank you.
I kick violently in my sleep I injured my cousin once I get my own bed now right in my sleep.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you But yeah, that's why I like all my calendar is getting more and more packed Every day because like I've been getting a lot of like offers to do like conventions or like events and stuff like that And I'm like, yes.
Yes.
Yes Like oh my god, I did like check my calendar.
I was like do I have an event?
I was like, oh my god Does this overlap with this other event that I'm doing across the world because obviously it's all like virtual so I'm like, okay We're good.
I'll be like, all right.
Yes, and I'll be like, okay does this okay?
This is the day This is gonna be the date before the other Convention so I can do both technically.
I'll be like yes
The reason why I'm taking a lot It's because I never had the opportunity and I don't know if obviously, you know I don't know if the next year I'll be I'll have the same chances again.
I'll have the same chance I'll have the same opportunity to be able to do a lot of these conventions to have like so many fans from around the world Supporting me and so like I don't know next year obviously, you know Next year, I don't know what I'm gonna my popularity is gonna be like next year,
you know I don't know if like, you know people If like I'll have the same opportunity As I do this year So that's why I'm just trying to like take as many chance the opportunities as I can before you know before We'll see what next year is gonna be next year Doki is gonna be so So that's why I'm trying to take as many chances to meet as many dragoons around the world as possible And like just to have these opportunities,
you know, they still need to be able to you know Sell the tickets and like be able to you know have enough people for the venue.
So I'm like, oh my god What if next year I don't have enough dragoons to fill up this venue?
And then they'll be like sorry Doki we can't get you because you can't fill up this venue So I'm like, okay, I gotta do it now I gotta use the momentum now because maybe now I have I have enough dragoons Now
I will always have imposter syndrome I'll never change I'll always have imposter syndrome.
So I'm so scared I'm so scared Anyway Let's see Mr. Brokenbond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for winning the Canadian Dollar collapses Shin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you Kids listen to Doki take advantage of us No!
No!
I didn't mean that!
Shin!
I do not endorse this super chat.
I do not endorse You're manipulating my words right now.
Hero, thank you for the five gift shits.
Thank you.
Thank you Bruce thank you for the super chat.
Thank you the dude who got Doki to come to a convention for a hundred bucks And a roll of lint.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you But yeah, it's been a lot of work behind Behind the scenes right now and I'm just really excited when I meant world tour.
Let's just say like I will have a convention.
I would be like I wish to be showing up at a convention in one of each maybe not obviously not fucking Antarctica but Almost every continent I will there will be a convention that I'll be going to for like that would be like a guest of so like I'll say that That like I won't get obviously I won't give names cuz like,
you know, we're still Negotiating and stuff.
So it's like I told you the world tour international world tour
What are things I want oh my god, okay.
I need to tell you guys the story I've been like holding back this store I've been holding back the story from the collab because like I realized like It's like such a weird story to tell but basically recently so Recently, I received some packages So I do have my own personal PO box for like receiving packages that is like,
you know receiving business packages and stuff from like events and like sponsors so like I end like from the auction to so like I have a personal PO Box for the auction items that I received and events and sponsors.
So a few days ago, my mom picked up the items from that PO Box and gave it to me.
And then we were opening up the packages.
So there was items in there from the auction and some sponsors.
So I was opening up the packages and I'm gonna have to use a code word.
So like it was going okay.
It was going okay.
I received some really cute plushies and stuff like in like artwork.
But then I opened one package and when I opened it up, it was like... I'm gonna use a code word because I don't want to get in trouble.
Okay, so when I opened it up, it was like a bag.
A bag of grass.
And I was freaking out.
Because I've never seen that before.
I've never seen... like I've never like seen it before.
Like... like ever.
Because I... you know... I...
I don't.
Like... I was freaking out.
Because I was like...
What the fuck?
What?
I was like... did my address... my PO Box get leaked?
I was freaking out.
I was like...
Oh my god.
Did my... who sent this?
Did my PO Box get leaked?
Like why is there...
Why is the bag of grass here?
I was like... oh my god.
I was freaking out.
Because I was like...
I was like... what is this?
And then... and then...
We... we saw the...
We looked at the package.
And then...
Apparently...
Someone else used to rent...
This PO Box.
But they didn't change the address.
So... so it got... so it got delivered to me.
Because it's my PO Box now.
But I...
I was so scared.
Because I legitimately thought...
That someone actually sent me a...
I don't know.
That someone leaked my address.
My PO Box address.
And then sent it to me.
Because I don't freaking know.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
And then my mom was like laughing at me.
Because like... it was just so ridiculous.
It was so freaking ridiculous.
I was... I was just like...
Holy fuck.
I was like... oh my god.
Am I going to go to jail?
Um...
So... so that... that happened to me like...
A couple of days ago.
I didn't want to tell the story.
On like the collab.
Because I was like... oh no.
That's going to be too awkward.
That's going to be so awkward.
Um...
Um... but yeah.
I legit...
I legit thought someone leaked my address.
I was freaking out.
And anyway...
But yes... anyway.
For the iBUYPOWER and the Hiit custom PC.
It's been in the works for like a while now.
Regarding like...
Um... the... the...
The custom PC itself.
By the way, this is like a custom, one of a kind PC made just for me.
And...
Um...
But... but...
Like I said on the tweet.
Look forward to future special announcements.
That may or may not...
Be related...
To like... a PC.
Hahahaha!
So if you're thinking...
Oh man...
Should I save my money?
For... I don't know...
Something related to like... I don't know...
PC stuff?
I don't know...
Maybe...
Hahahaha!
It might be...
Might be a hard... maybe!
I don't know...
I cannot confirm...
Or deny anything...
At the moment...
Just... maybe...
Hahahaha!
Um...
Fiction!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Seen in recent events.
Can you play my...
Um...
So franchise... franchise...
Gears of War, please?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Thank... Wait, what?
What does that even mean?
What is this?
Is this a... Was this like a chat GPT Super chat?
Is that an actual sentence?
Seen in recent events.
Can you play my...
Soul franchise Gears of War?
Please?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Not a good username.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh!
Gears of War is getting another game soon!
Oh, that would be sick!
I want to play the original...
first though.
Um...
I really want to play the original events...
Original Gears of War games before I touch the...
Um...
Before I touch the...
Uh... the newest one.
Um... I've always watched my dad...
I watched my dad play the first three Gears of Wars as a little...
as a little dokey.
So...
I really wanted to experience it myself.
I heard the new Fallout show was really good!
Uh...
I was like... I was planning on watching the new Fallout show because...
What's his name?
Kojumbo?
Recommen... Sorry.
Uh...
Sorry.
Uh... Jimbo's done it again.
Uh... but he like...
recommended on... he recommended on Twitter.
Every time he recommends stuff on Twitter...
He's... I don't know.
It's usually been like pretty accurate.
And like...
When he doesn't like some... When he doesn't like a show, he'll just be like...
I watched this show.
But if he does like it, he'll just be like... Oh my god!
It was pretty good!
I just love like... his reviews.
Because it's so obvious when he doesn't like anything.
He'll just be like... I watched it.
And...
But then if it's something he enjoyed, he'd be like...
Oh my god!
It's so good!
Like... the actress was pretty... pretty well... like the acting was pretty well done.
Versus... I watched this.
What a... What a lad.
What?
What a lad.
Let's see.
Kaz!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kojimbo is the father of pure cinema.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yes.
Anyway.
I just realized we did like a fucking 23 minute like catch up Zatsu without actually doing the game.
But for those who don't know, this game is called Would You Rather?
And basically, it's like when you press the button.
It's like all the...
These are like basically like...
stream games type deal.
Because they were super popular back in the day.
Like back with like Let's Players.
So like when you press the button.
Would you rather?
What's the other one?
Ask the genie guy.
I forgot his name.
And then it was higher or lower.
Stuff like that.
Anyway.
I realized.
Oh my god.
I can finally do Would You Rather?
And so basically, they gave us two choices.
Would you rather?
And then when you pick a choice, you get to see who is like the majority pick.
Like oh which side did the majority of people want to pick.
And stuff like that.
So you know if you're like the majority.
You're like the...
You're like a sheep or you know you have your own way of thinking.
You think outside the box and everything.
So it's like basically like the Walking Dead shit.
So you know they'll be like your choices.
Here are the people who made the same choice as you.
Stuff like that.
But this one is more like Would You Rather?
Um...
Anyway.
So.
Would you rather scream loudly while you're asleep or be blind and deaf for the first 30 minutes after waking up?
I would honestly choose scream loudly while you're asleep.
Because I feel like you know how there's like those like uh... like those like sleep deprivation tanks?
What's the sleep depri... no.
Sensory depra... sorry not sleep depri...
Sensory um... those like sensory deprivation tanks.
And then when you go into like those sensory tanks you like fucking like go insane.
You can... the longer you spend in there the more insane you get.
Because when you don't have your senses like you turn crazy or something.
So I feel like if this happens to me everyday I think I go crazy.
I feel like like 30 minutes of just nothingness by myself I feel like I just go insane in general.
And I feel everything.
I don't wanna feel stuff better.
I feel like cause then like you can't hear or see right?
But that doesn't stop your fucking inner demons demons or your imagination.
So I feel like your inner demons and your imagination would go fucking wild.
Because you know for the first 30 minutes cause you're trying to like invent something in your head.
Especially if you have like a super active imagination.
And stuff.
So I'm just like that doesn't sound fun.
And I don't wanna like feel something more intensely too.
Cause like you know what's that thing where you can't see or like hear your other senses start improving more?
And I don't like that.
My other senses don't need to improve anymore.
I don't wanna feel stuff more.
I'm okay.
I'm okay with the current amount of feeling.
So...
So I'd rather I just... cause like screaming loudly while you're asleep.
It just happens when you're asleep.
So like it only affects other people.
Like it affects my neighbor.
That's fine.
Fuck my neighbors.
Like who cares about what they think.
Call me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Scream loudly while sleeping because I'm not the one being...
Yeah exactly.
It's not affecting me.
Like who cares about...
...
It's not affecting me.
I'm gonna need a...
I may be... okay.
Someone made a good point.
It will affect my throat.
But like what if like... but what if like...
you know... I just like tape my mouth shut.
I'll still be like silently screaming.
So um... mmm...
like mmm...
is less work than... ahh...
So...
in the end...
in the end... it wouldn't...
I'll just drink a lot of fucking...
warm water.
Okay.
Maybe... maybe I'll sleep...
I'll do like... you know... maybe I'll do like...
like... what is like...
intense naps like those like...
There's like a sleep cycle where you only sleep like every certain interval.
So if I sleep... if I change my sleep schedule in a way where I only sleep like particular intervals like REM sleep...
what is like power naps and stuff like that.
The REM cycle.
Then I'll be fine.
That'll be fine.
I mean...
It's... it's productive.
It could be productive.
Some people say it...
You think it's not healthy.
But then...
But... you don't...
You think it's not healthy.
But how would you know that?
Have you ever tried?
Yeah!
Checkmate!
Don't try this by the way.
Don't... sleep a normal sleep schedule.
Only if you have scream loudly while you're asleep.
Anyway...
I think scream loudly while you're asleep is the way to go.
Oh...
Well...
Those people!
Don't know what they're talking about.
They're fucking sheep.
Nice!
They're just sheep!
They don't... they're not cultured enough.
They're not smart enough.
That 39... I don't know.
Was it 31?
That 31% is like... those...
It's like... you know how they're like...
You need to be smart enough to understand Rick and Morty.
It's like being the 1% chat.
I was being the 1% guys.
Because I know what I'm talking about.
.
Alright.
Be able to explore the universe.
Or be able to explore the unknowns of the earth.
Okay, I'm not even gonna make a poll.
I was gonna make a poll.
But like...
I don't even have to debate.
I'll be the universe.
Because usually to explore the unknowns of the earth is just like primitive stuff.
Like, you know... Just be like, here's a forest.
Like...
Here's a forest that's never been explored before.
I don't care.
Like, you know what lives in a forest?
Fucking insects and bugs.
You know what lives in the fucking univ... Like, we don't know what lives in the universe.
There could be aliens.
To be fair, we're gonna be the aliens if we're exploring the universe.
But like...
One is obvious, the choice.
Like, what kind of question is that?
Like, 39%?
Like, oh my god.
Those guys are stupid.
Now, those guys are definitely stupid.
Be stranded in the jungle or be strand...
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't even need to make a poll of this either.
Of course the jungle.
The desert has no water.
The jungle?
I can chop a coconut.
Like, there's more chances to die in the desert from dehydration and hunger than there is to the jungle.
And also sunburn.
Dude, fuck the sun.
But don't fuck the sun.
Exactly.
The desert has nothing.
The jung... Yes, the jungle has wild animals that I can kill and then eat.
Guys.
The animals in the jungle are food.
It's so easy.
Oh, what about the poisonous frogs?
What about the poisonous scorpions and snakes?
Snakes exist in both.
Like, what the fuck do you mean?
There's snakes in the desert too.
You can't avoid them.
They're everywhere.
Yeah, but there's always water in your sand.
Like, you said, right?
It's all one big beach.
Eventually!
But I don't have a horse to find the water, Kaz.
Look.
So, that's what I'm saying.
Like, there's already scorpions and snakes in the desert.
And also the jungle.
At least the jungle has, like, animals I can eat and also water I can drink easily.
Lots of predators?
There's lots of predators in the desert too!
You just don't...
There's a lot of predators in the desert too!
It's just that they wait for you to die and eat you instead because it's just easier.
You just die by the desert before you die by the jungle.
Like...
Like, you die by the whole ecosystem of the desert first before any predators fucking comes in to eat you.
Alright.
I bet you I'm the majority here.
I swear!
See?
Look, you're the 16%!
And that's not the special lower percent like I was in the beginning.
That was the...
That was the you are wrong percentage.
Alright.
Spend your entire... Okay, this one I'll make a poll.
I'll make a poll for this.
She's right, guys.
Exactly!
Of course I'm right!
Summer at beach versus summer in mountains.
Oh my god, no.
Fuck the beach.
There's no way I'm gonna choose the beach.
The beach fucking sucks.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, here's why.
Here's the reason why.
The beach...
Okay, but like, what is the scope of the mountains though?
Like, how tall is the mountain?
Is it like...
Is it so tall that I can't breathe?
Like, I need like an oxygen tank to breathe?
Like, or is it like...
Is like Mount Everest type of mountain?
Or is it just a regular mountain?
Like a hill?
Is a hill a mountain?
Or is a hill like a baby mountain?
Anyway, no.
Fuck the beach.
No matter what, I don't like beaches.
I hate the... I hate the sand.
I hate sand.
And then I hate the ocean.
Because the ocean is just like nature's bathroom.
And like, you know like the sewers eventually lead to the ocean.
You guys know that, right?
The sewer...
The sewers... Sewages eventually leads to the ocean.
And like, if you think about it, the ocean is not just filled with just the nature's.
I'm not...
It's not just the nature's toilet.
It's everybody's toilet.
It's everywhere.
And that is why I would never pick the beach.
That's why like, ever since like the realization of me um, ever since like the real... Oh yeah, and microplastics by the way.
Ever since the realization when I was like younger, that I was like, wait, fishes poop and pee in the ocean.
I've never been to the... Like, I've never like touched the ocean water since.
Because like, you can't be like, oh I'll just like I'll just close my mouth and not breathe the water... Like not like have the water in my...
The water's gonna be in your body no matter what.
Like...
The water is gonna be... You're gonna taste the water no matter what.
And ever since then, I just don't wanna touch the ocean ever since.
Ever since that part.
Um...
Fletchtop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sudoki, you rather go hiking?
Remember the last time you went hiking?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, but that doesn't mean I'm gonna be hiking in the mountains.
What if it's a fucking city on the mountain?
You don't know that.
It never said anything regarding hiking.
There could be literally an uh... an apartment built onto this mountain and I just never go outside.
Like you heard of like cabin in the woods.
This could be like apartment on the mountain.
Like...
It could be a cool ass resort.
You don't know that.
Same for the beach?
Yes, but the beach still has the fucking sand and the ocean.
The mountains doesn't have sand.
Um...
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The ocean is salty because of the baby fish.
No!
Oh my god, no!
You know what's in the ocean?
Trash island.
You all remember trash island?
That's in the ocean.
There's not just one trash island.
There's several trash islands.
You know what's not on the mountains?
Trash island.
There, checkmate.
Like...
Um...
I feel like any physical activity doki wood.
That is not true!
I am a very good hiker.
I just choose not to hike because it's a terrible experience.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Anyway, so yes, I am gonna choose spend the entire summer in the mountains.
People who choose the beach are not aware about the ocean's toilet.
Or sorry, nature's toilet.
Okay, you guys are fucking idiots.
Oh my god!
Oh!
I'm so...
I don't feel comfortable answering this question.
Okay... Okay...
Okay...
Sorry, I did not feel comfortable debating this.
Um...
Cowardice?
Bro...
Stop being a coward.
It's called...
It's called ethics.
Everyone has...
Everyone has a code of ethics.
That was my line.
That was...
That...
That... That was my line.
Okay... Um...
Okay... Okay...
Burnt food versus bite tongue.
I would honestly say...
Um...
I would vote...
Oh my gosh.
But how hard would you bite your tongue?
Cause it's never...
Your tongue is gonna get like scarred up and shit.
And it... Yeah, they both... Okay...
Is it true that eating burnt food gives you cancer?
Cause that's what my mom would always tell me.
I don't know if it's like one of those like...
Those like mom stories.
You know, mom lies and stuff.
So like I can't tell if it's like mom lies.
Uh... But yes.
Like I...
Cause like I always like burnt food.
Okay.
But like not...
Okay, not like oh I'll always eat burnt food.
But like I always like the crunch of burnt food.
So like you know the burnt crust and stuff.
Not like super burnt crust but like you know a little bit of burnt stuff.
And then like of the crunch.
And then my mom would always be like don't eat burnt food.
You're gonna get cancer.
So I don't know.
But then there's like a lot of those mom lies.
Um...
The mom lies that like they say it.
Because like a lot of moms would say it.
Because like you know parents love to do scare tactics for children to not do the things they wanna do.
So they'll be like don't eat this.
Or you're gonna get cancer.
Don't eat that or you're gonna get cancer.
Don't do this or you're gonna get cancer.
Like it was...
Um...
It's always something related to cancer.
Uh because another thing.
The mom lies.
Like oh don't put your phone too near your head.
You're gonna get cancer.
From the radiation.
The radiation rays from the fucking phone.
From the fucking phone.
So...
So like the 5G's are gonna cause cancer in your brain.
And stuff.
If you put your phone...
If you like...
If you like fall asleep with the phone in your bed.
So, I don't know if that's true also.
Because I'm fucked out of way.
Because I go to... I fucking play with my phone when I sleep.
So, I don't know actually.
But I still do it.
So, well, we'll see how lucky I am.
Okay, anyway.
But like, how burnt is that food though?
And I feel like biting your tongue is not great.
Because it's not a great experience.
And like, biting your tongue is never...
And like, having that fucking...
You know, like when the tongue starts getting swollen at the part where you bit and stuff.
It's not really...
Nice experience.
And it's every time you eat.
It's every day.
Your fucking tongue is gonna get so...
Scarred up and like...
Beefed out.
Because like, you know, it's gonna be like...
Resilient to more bites.
And like, exactly.
Someone was like...
Hiro was like, thank you Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was like, you'll get an infection.
So, at that point, I won't die from cancer.
I'll just die from like, infections.
I mean, they're both terrible.
I won't die from the burnt food that caused cancer.
I'll just die from a fucking infection.
Because eventually...
My odds are not with me.
At that point.
Because it's every time I eat.
So like, an infection will get there somehow.
What if I want to eat like...
Like...
I don't know.
What if I want to eat something that's a little raw?
Like, that's gonna fucking suck.
So I'm gonna go with burnt food.
Because...
I don't know how burnt it is.
Um...
And my mom said it doesn't cause cancer.
So...
Clearly my moderator knows what's up.
So I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go with burnt food.
Uh...
Largus.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We survived centuries of lead water pipes and mercury household products.
We can survive bacon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why the fuck?
Who chose?
What is the ten...
Those are the people who believe that burnt food will cause cancer.
Like, there's no way.
Why would you choose...
I don't know.
Why would you choose pain?
Like, why would you choose pain over like burnt food?
You don't know how burnt it is.
Like, you can't burn everything.
What if I just drink soup the entire...
The rest of my life?
Like...
No.
What if...
What if I just...
You can't burn soup.
Okay, maybe you can.
You can burn soup a little bit.
But it's a liquid.
It's like you can't burn water.
I don't know.
How do you burn cereal?
There's no way.
What if...
What if it's more...
Marshmallows.
Burnt marshmallows is okay.
Like...
Burnt marshmallows is like alright.
I can pick and choose my food.
There's one...
There has to be a food that like bypasses the burnt laws.
Okay, sing versus dance.
Oh, 100% sing.
Like, you can make more money singing than dancing.
Okay.
I am so sorry.
I feel like...
Like profit wise and like...
And just like in general singing is just the easiest way.
Like I can make a million fucking covers in original songs.
Like albums and stuff.
People will...
More people will buy albums and songs than fucking dance videos and stuff.
Like a singer can...
Can...
Don't have to be a dancer.
But a dancer...
If they want to be like a famous dancer...
They'll have to also sort of be a singer.
Because like...
You know...
There's like lots of dance covers.
Like...
Or be in a dance group.
I feel like...
The only way you can sort of be famous as a dancer is if you're like in a dance group.
Or you're just a coach of a famous singer.
Like...
Because you know...
Singers need to hire dance coaches.
So I feel like the only way that you can like make money as a dancer...
Is just to be like a dance coach of some...
Like someone famous.
Or like be on a reality TV show for dancers.
Like...
So you think you can dance.
Do you remember?
So you think you can dance?
That shit?
And what are they...
What the celebrities and stuff?
And then what's her name?
That mom that had eight kids?
What was it?
Six kids?
The six tuplets?
Was on that show?
The original Karen?
Oh my god.
So you think you can dance?
Does that still exist in any way?
I remember there was like...
An episode of So You Think You Can Dance?
Where it was just...
Oh my god.
What was it?
Was it like a weeb version of So You Think You Can Dance?
Oh my god.
I'm trying to remember.
There was like...
There was like viral clip from So You Think You Can Dance?
Where it was some...
They like made a reference to like...
Anime culture.
I don't remember which one it was.
It was like...
It went viral on Twitter for a little bit.
Yeah.
And you're like...
I can't remember what...
Thing they were referencing though.
I don't think it was an American version.
It was like some other fucking country.
I didn't.
Honestly, I think reality TV show is dying though.
There hasn't been like actual good reality TV in a long ass time.
Because like ethically it's like you know...
Because people realize...
People realize now that like watching these things on reality TV is not right morally and ethically.
It was never good.
If you think of...
Because people are like...
Wait a minute.
Is it...
People are like...
Oh my god.
Is it really bad to like...
Watch these little children do beauty contests?
And then show the world how fucked up the...
Like how fucked up kids pageants are.
But like...
But like frame it as a good thing.
Because I used to watch Diamonds and Tiaras a lot.
As a...
As a younger doki.
I watched like...
Diamonds and Tiaras a lot and I didn't realize things were wrong.
I didn't realize how bad the show was.
Until I was a little older.
Because that show...
Oh yeah sorry.
Toddlers and Tiaras.
Um...
Because for those who've never watched Toddlers and Tiaras.
It's basically like a reality TV show following around like real people by the way.
They're not like celebrities or anything.
They're real people.
Real children.
Um...
Who do like beauty pageants.
Like kids.
Doing beauty pageants.
And then they talk about like you know the stuff they have to do.
The sacrifices they have to make.
The parents who feed them a lot of sugar.
Like those like pixie sticks.
Where it's just sugar.
And then they'll be like...
Oh you're tired?
You're like...
Oh my god.
My daughter's tired.
Don't worry.
Here's three sticks of pixie sticks.
So you can stay awake for the rest of the pageant.
And like for like 30 seconds.
Like they'll be like...
And then they'll be like oh my god.
Wow.
Oh my god.Me Dex.
That's so funny.
I love know that a lot of times...
You don't know the girl you're dating.
Don't think she's going to move.
You don't know your the point of Jaime and Tiaras is.
So like you don't know what the point of this going to be.
You don't know what the point of this is going to.... And the bottom line is like...
I'm so sorry.
I didn't win this pageant.
Because it's a beauty pageant.
And it was so and so bad.
But I was just like, aww.
She did, you know, Lil Doki would just be like, aww, she didn't work hard enough to win.
There was just someone that was just better.
And then now, I'm like, oh my god, this is so fucked up.
These little kids are gonna...
These little kids grew up to be so fucked up.
With their own perception of like, who they are as a person.
Because they didn't...
Because of beauty pageants.
I wanna know what happened to these traumatized kids.
That is so easy to look for.
Just look at Honey Boo Boo.
Oh my god.
Like, I think like, because of what happened with the whole Honey Boo Boo shit.
Because like, I know like their parents got divorced and stuff right after.
Um, cause like, the dad wasn't like super into the whole beauty pageant thing.
And like, you know, the mom was like, this made us famous.
What are you talking about?
Uh, yeah, the kids were never being normal.
After that.
Um, and then like, Honey Boo Boo apparently was like, super fucking depressed too.
During that.
Like, she did like an interview being like, oh yeah, like, oh, I got like super depressed.
And stuff.
Um...
And...
Yeah, it's just Ashley is so fucked up.
Anyway, we realize now that reality TV...
Re-reality TV was actually pretty messed up.
It was entertaining.
But then it got, it was like...
It was entertaining like in, like, you know, if you don't look past it.
But then when you think about what the fuck is going on, we're like whoa.
You know, maybe this is pretty fucked up.
Maybe...
Maybe this shit was pretty fucking bad.
Like...
Um...
And then what else?
What else?
Oh yeah.
And there was also like, uh, oh my gosh.
I think like...
Have you guys ever read that article when, you know, the pandemic started?
And then the people in Big Brother had to had to like stop filming and they had to let them go.
Like they had to stop filming.
And then the contestants on Big Brother was like...
Just found out everything that was going on regarding the pandemic.
Like at once.
That was so fucked up.
So everyone was like what the fuck are you talking about, Doki?
So Big Brother...
Big Brother is a reality TV show where...
They grab a bunch of contestants.
They could be like, you know, internet famous people or semi reality stars.
Um...
And everything.
Or like they'll just be regular people.
And then they lock them in a...
They lock them in a house.
In a mansion.
And then they don't let them see anything on the internet.
Like no news on TV.
Nothing.
Like no media.
Like they're just locked.
Like actual quarantine.
But before the quarantine existed.
So it was basically like Big Brother had a quarantine but there was no pandemic.
But then, you know, the pandemic happened.
And then... but the people in Big Brother didn't know what the fuck was going on.
They...
They did not know.
Um... They didn't know what was going on in the outside world.
They had zero idea what the fuck was happening.
And then...
And then they were like...
Obviously they couldn't continue filming.
Because, you know, the production people need to be quarantined.
You know, they're like, we can't keep doing this.
Like the production people are like, we can't keep doing this.
Like, you know, they have to maintain the house as well.
You know?
Like the...
Like they have to take out the trash and everything.
But the production people are like, we don't feel safe keep doing this.
So...
We can't keep doing this any longer.
We need to tell them.
We need to tell them that the world is going...
is exploding right now.
And...
But yeah, like they had to let them... They had to like give them a reality check.
While the pandemic started getting really bad.
It was... I was like Bro, that must have been fucking terrible.
Holy shit.
Oh shit!
That was been so... they're like, oh I can't wait for Big Brother.
I can't wait after Big Brother when like I get to go home and hang out with my family and not have to worry about the toilet paper shortage.
And so yeah, so then there's like a clip of... there was a clip of stuff of like giving them the news and stuff about like being like, yeah, while you were being filmed in Big Brother, some shit was going on in the outside world.
And then the contestants were just shocked.
They were like, is this part of the show?
They were just like... the contestants were just like...
Is this... is this part of the show?
Are we... are we really... like no, that can't be real.
That can't... that can't be real.
So... they went from one quarantine to another quarantine right after.
It's like, is this a bit like... oh my god.
It was so crazy.
Anyway... I don't know how I got to reality TV talking about singing.
Oh yeah, dancing with the stars.
But yeah, anyway, I would choose singing because I feel like I could do more with the singing than I can with the dancing if I had to choose one or the other.
Actual... you guys are acting, right?
Yeah, acting.
Yeah, I figured... I figured.
Name a famous dancer.
Name... name five famous dancers on the top of your head.
I bet you can't.
I bet you can name like one or two.
But I bet you can't name five.
And they're like only dancers.
Not like singing dancers.
It's just dancers.
Alright, Pantsy, thank you for 50 gift shits.
Thank you, thank you.
Me.
No, you can't say Michael Jackson because that's a singer and dancer.
You can't say that.
It has to be like dancers.
Like they're famous because of dancing.
Not because of singing.
You can't say Michael Jackson because Michael Jackson was famous in the Jackson 5.
And he was like a singer in Jackson 5.
It's not because of like the dancing back then.
But I can name five famous singers on the top of my head.
Always have the best hair.
Always have the best... neither.
I don't fucking...
Actually, best outfit.
No.
Okay, I'm thinking like design wise.
I think like...
Okay, design wise, I feel like outfit matters more than hair.
I think.
Because you can have a generic hairstyle.
But if you have a really good outfit to match along, it's memorable.
So I would say best outfit because I feel like best...
Also, it's more comfy too.
Like the better the outfit, the more comfy it is as well.
So I'd rather go with... I'm not even going to do a poll for this because I want to skip this question.
I will do best outfit.
What did I get for best outfit?
Oh yeah, nice 60%.
I knew I was the majority.
Alright.
Make 350k a year robbing innocent people.
Make 40k a year helping people in...
How innocent are they?
They can't be full on innocent.
Come on.
Okay.
Three...
50k versus 40k.
Okay.
I'll be like...
But Doki, what about the content?
This is the content.
Look.
It can be sort of like robbing hood.
You know?
I rob from the rich to give to the poor.
I'm the one that's...
Sorry, not poor.
Rob from the rich to give to the poor.
Give to the less fortunate.
I am the less fortunate.
I am Lord Curiosus.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Outfit.
You can be bald and a good suit still looks great.
Totally not expecting from experience.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Exactly!
That's exactly what I thought.
Call me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Aren't you a...
Exactly.
I'm a thief.
So of course I'll be robbing people.
Like...
What if it's like...
Okay.
But like...
I can also like...
Give to...
Give the money to the fortunate people in need as well.
Guys.
It could also do that.
It doesn't mean that, you know...
I just take the 350k and then not do anything after that.
I could like, you know...
Take 350k and then I'll help the people I robbed.
They could be innocent rich people.
They might...
Like that money might be nothing for them.
You know?
It could be Bill Gates.
I could have...
I could have like robbed Bill Gates 350k.
He doesn't care.
350k is nothing to him.
I'll just rob a billionaire who didn't...
Who like...
Was an ethical billionaire.
Because like we all know there's some billionaires out there that are definitely not innocent.
I don't know.
Zach, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We all know.
Guys.
There were a lot of billionaires out there that might have got that billions of dollars via unethical means.
There's no way you can make a billion dollars doing stuff the right way.
No, don't say that.
No billionaires...
Don't say that.
Other than the fact that Bill Gates is burning.
Like, don't...
Why did Bill Gates divorce with his fucking wife after being married for so fucking long?
A lot of people forgot the reason why they divorced was because Bill Gates cheated on his wife.
Like, I feel like a lot of people forgot about that.
Because, like...
Everyone will be like, oh, but Bill Gates...
But...
But Bill Gates...
He's just like...
A lovable grandpa.
Like, he's just...
He's just like a lovable grandpa.
But then, like...
But then people forgot...
The reason why he, you know...
Isn't married to his wife anymore.
Who he's been together with for...
For decades.
People never forgot about that.
So it's like, I didn't even know he was married.
Yeah.
Yeah, he was.
He was married.
Also, what's his name?
Amazon guy.
Also, the Amazon guy as well...
You know, like...
His wife basically, like, supported him.
His wife basically supported him to start Amazon.
So, like...
Jeff Bezos.
I can't believe I forgot his name.
Mr. Bezos.
But, basically, like...
When Jeff Bezos was like...
He was like, you know, oh, I started...
I started Amazon off of my garage.
I quit my job.
Okay, so I just got a job and started this passion project of the fucking garage thing.
People forgot that part of the story that people don't remember is that his wife had a high paying job.
His wife had a high paying job and basically supported him when he was doing the Amazon thing out of the garage.
So it's not because of the whole, you know, oh my god he did...
Because you know how people are like, I'm gonna drop out of school and become the next Facebook creator.
Stuff like that.
They're like, oh, Mark Zuckerberg...
I'm gonna be just like Mark Zuckerberg and Jeff Bezos and become a billionaire.
Because all they did was follow their dreams.
Thing is, a lot of those people...
A lot of these people have...
Also, like, you're not... your university's not Harvard.
There's also that too.
You're not a Harvard dropout.
There's that as well.
Because no matter what, being a Harvard dropout still fucking brings you clout because you made it into Harvard.
But yeah, but anyway, they had a lot of resources.
They weren't poor.
They got...
It's either their parents were super fucking rich and they gave them a loan or...
Or like, they were actually supported by...
They were also like supported by like their spouses and stuff.
Like, they'll be like, it's okay, sweetie.
You can go to do your dream project.
I'm gonna fucking still go to my job.
Support you.
Anyway, what was this tangent?
Jeff Bezos divorced his wife too.
That was where my tangent is to not...
I don't think any billionaire in the world is clean.
I don't think...
Yeah, Mr. Be...
There was a whole thing about it.
There was a whole thing because like...
Because like the wife didn't sign a prenup.
So she basically took 50% of Bezos stuff and Bezos was so fucking angry.
He was so mad.
Because like, you know, they didn't sign a prenup because when they got married, he wasn't rich yet.
He wasn't rich yet.
So...
So like she actually got 50% of everything.
Um...
Uh...
Maggie, thank you for the magenta soup.
But thank you, thank...
And he's still very rich.
Even if he got like 50% of everything, he's still very rich.
Like...
There's...
He's gonna die and he's still be a billionaire.
There's no way.
There's nothing...
He can go...
He can like spend...
He can spend like...
I don't know.
50% of what he...
50% of what he makes and he's still gonna be a billionaire.
His wife took 50% of his fucking...
Like his...
Like his wife took 50% of everything he makes.
He's still a fucking billionaire.
It doesn't matter.
Like...
He can spend 98%...
Yeah.
That guy.
He can spend 98% of his entire net worth.
And he'll still die fucking more rich than like 98% of what he makes.
That's just what's shit's like.
Just like...
Just like shit.
Like a, man.
But.
Like...
Just like shit.
Can nobody fucking todas take that shit off.
Like, he can afford to charge for it if he wants, I don't know.
This is just awkward.
It's not like it's anymore...
There.
You scream.
What do you call shit?
You've got to find other people who...
You've got to find other people who are bullish in the...
We're done for today.
I like how I went through that entire tangent.
Anyway, I will rob innocent people if those innocent people were billionaires.
Because they don't care.
Or millionaires.
You know what?
Millionaires and billionaires.
Because there's some actual innocent millionaires.
Anyway, this justifies me robbing the rich because they don't care.
They don't care.
That's nothing to them.
$350,000 is nothing to a billionaire and a millionaire.
It's just like... it's what they make in one day.
It's literally what they make in one day.
So they'll not even realize it's God.
It says, innocent, look.
There has to be innocent millionaires in there.
I believe there's innocent millionaires in there.
It's so wrong.
Look.
If you think about it.
My wrong turns into a right.
I can literally rob just one innocent millionaire or billionaire.
And they won't notice.
I'll just rob one of them.
And they won't notice at all.
I'll rob a baby.
A millionaire's child.
They have to be innocent by then.
Because, you know, it's not their fault if they're super greedy.
It's not the child's fault if they're super spoiled.
They were just raised to be like that.
So I'll just rob...
I'm pretty sure when the baby is born, they instantly become a millionaire.
So I'll rob the baby.
And then the billionaire will just give them back the money.
They'll just be like, oh, child.
What if the child is holding a sack of money and it's $350,000?
I'll just steal that sack of money.
And then the millionaire will be like, oh, sweetie, don't cry.
Here's another million dollars for you to fucking sleep on.
I don't know.
I don't know what they do.
I don't know what those kids do.
So let's... thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you a point-slope formula because you keep giving us all the tangents?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look, all I'm saying is that it won't be that bad if I, like, steal from one innocent baby.
Because they won't notice it's gone.
They will not notice it's gone.
That's all I'm saying.
All that... those people are... those people are fucking stupid.
They are not thinking at the level I'm thinking right now.
What the fuck am I gonna do with math?
Sorry, we're not voting on this.
Why would... it be 50-50.
What would you do with math?
You have a phone.
What... what will help you?
What will help you with math?
You're gonna fucking calculate the number of...
the time it's gonna take for you to drive from one end to another?
You know what's not gonna help...
You know what else can help you with that?
Fucking Google Maps.
Learn engineering?
Just don't be an engineer!
If you're... if you're already pursuing engineering as a degree, you don't need to be proficient in math because you're already proficient in math.
I need math to be CiderFat.
Guys, if you're already proficient in math, you're already trying... if you're already trying to be an engineer, you're already proficient in math.
Because why the fuck would you go towards being an engineer?
How does that make sense?
It... what do you mean how does that make sense?
Taxes... just pay someone to fucking figure out your...
Oh, wait.
Something... I just realized like... like...
Not a lot of people have the opportunity to do that.
I'm so sorry.
Sorry.
Some people...
Sorry, I have to have someone to do my taxes because I'm like...
I can't do math and also like... I can afford...
I'm fortunate enough to be able...
to be able...
to... to afford an accountant...
to afford an accountant to check through my taxes for me.
Okay.
Celeste, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm an engineer and an accountant and a former math teacher and I took that personally.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But it's because you're already good at math, Celeste.
You're already good at math.
You don't need to be proficient.
You already have that skill.
You chose that career because you have that skill already.
There's a reason why I'm not a math teacher or an accountant or an engineer.
Before I had the...
Before I had the money to afford an accountant.
Do you know who does my taxes?
Who helps me with my taxes?
My parents because I was so fucking stupid.
I am still very stupid.
I'm so...
I don't want to trust me with numbers.
Because I don't trust myself with numbers.
I'm just that dumb.
I just need you guys to know when I did the IB program, when I did the international baccalaureate.
You have to like do suggestions and stuff.
Like you have to give like what classes are you going to take.
For those who don't know.
The international baccalaureate is one of the hard...
I don't know if it still is.
But back when I took the international baccalaureate.
It's one of the hardest courses you can take in high school.
So like if you pass the IB program.
It's basically like a higher tier than AP.
So it's like a higher...
It's like one of the highest tiers for like school.
Like for schooling.
And if you pass it.
If you pass the IB program.
You basically you can get college credit for free.
Like you can get like bonus college credit.
So you can like graduate like one to two years early.
Basically.
So I did the IB program.
And I passed the IB program.
And I got like college credit.
So I could graduate early.
But if you can...
If you get like really good scores.
It's like almost guarantee IB league.
Unless you fail the interview.
Because we had...
I remember there was like a student.
Like she was...
Oh I told this story a long time ago.
But there was this girl.
I know.
In the IB program.
And like a lot of people were like scared of her.
Because she would wear like a fanning pack.
She would wear like a fanning pack around.
And like she had like knives in that fanning pack.
Like...
And like her...
Like she would say like her dream is to be a Yandere.
She would be like I want to be a Yandere.
To us.
Because like I hang out with her.
And like other...
She was like in the group I hang out with.
I didn't want to piss...
I didn't...
Like I wanted to be her friend.
Because she was like...
She's like incredibly smart.
And I didn't want to piss her off.
Because one of my friends told me that someone like pissed her off.
One time.
Like before like I became friends with her.
Like one of my other friends told me.
Was like don't piss her off.
Because she got suspended once because she pulled a knife on somebody.
And I was like...
And so...
So I was like...
Gotcha.
I'm gonna be good friends with her.
Okay.
Anyway.
So...
But anyways.
She got a perfect score in the IB program.
Like she got like a...
Full marks basically in IB.
Like which is like really really...
Fucking good.
Like it's like almost impossible to get.
Like it's almost like...
It's very very...
It's like the 1%.
It's basically the 1% to get a perfect score.
Like the perfect 45.
And she got that.
And her first choice...
Her first choice was Harvard.
And...
And she got waitlisted from Harvard.
Because of her interview.
And she got like a perfect score.
Because usually...
When you get a perfect score...
That...
Uh...
You...
It's almost guaranteed...
IB...
Like guaranteed first choice pick...
In any IB league school.
Because it's that difficult to get in.
But because like...
She was very intimidating.
I'll just say she was like...
Incredibly intimidating in person.
Uh...
No she did not get into Harvard.
She got into...
What is that...
MIT.
She got into MIT.
Uh...
Because she wanted to be an engineer.
So like...
She chose MIT after getting waitlisted to Harvard.
Uh...
Anyway...
That was not the story...
My story was that...
My story...
The story was that basically when you're supposed to give your class choices, there's like three levels of math.
It's standard level, higher level, or baby level.
Studies.
Math studies.
Math studies is like baby level math.
And then there's standard level and then there's higher level.
The counselor, the academic counselor was like, I think Doki should do studies.
After I put standard level, I put standard level.
But the counselor looked at my list and was like, you should do studies.
And then I told my parents that.
They're like, oh they want me to do math studies.
And then my parents were mad and was like, she is not doing math studies.
We will get her tutors so she can do standard.
She will have math tutors almost every other day.
So she can do standard level.
So then the counselor was like, okay.
The reason why was because they were afraid.
The counselor was afraid that if I...
Because the reason why is because the school was one of those things where obviously the grades really mattered.
Because they always post out like, oh our school got the average rating.
The average.
Like IB score is this.
So they try to convince a lot of like...
They try to convince people who they think are too dumb to take IB to do the lower rank pro...
To do the other program.
Because they don't want them to affect the average IB score that the school has.
So they'll be like...
They'll be like, oh we don't think you should take IB.
You should take that one instead.
It will be so much better for you.
So they don't want them to like affect the average.
They don't want them to bring the average down.
Like they were trying to tamper the stats and stuff.
So that's why they were like, we think Doki should take studies.
So...
Because they were afraid.
They were afraid that my math score was going to lower the fucking IB score.
They were so scared.
So they were trying to convince my parents and I to take studies.
Anyway...
That is why...
This entire tangent is why...
Is why I was not born to do math.
That is...
That's basically it.
This took me like 20 minutes to explain.
But that was the story.
I should not be in charge of anything math related.
It got to the point where even the counselor was like, I don't think she should be in this level.
Anyway...
Would you rather...
Sorry, we were supposed to...
I think they were...
They were, they were 100...
I was so down to do math studies by the way.
But it was all an ego thing for my parents.
Because they didn't want a child to do math studies.
Cause like, that's a little...
I guess that's a little embarrassing.
Because everybody else is like standard level.
And then like...
Me, I would be in the studies level.
Which is basically...
I'm being like, she can't do fucking math.
Okay, be able to walk on water.
Okay, obviously fire.
We don't even need a pool.
You all know my opinion about the water.
Like why the fuck would I need a... bro, what the fuck?
I'd rather just like... okay.
Water?
I'll just have like a fucking... what's it called?
Those little lifesavers?
I'll just put on those little lifesavers or those life jackets.
Why do I need that?
I could just touch fire?
You need so much protection for fire.
So like you need to have so much protection.
And like... and like what if somebody's drowning?
What can I do?
I can't go in the water and like fucking save them.
But if somebody is like on fire... if a building is on fire...
And then there's no firefighters around and I'm walking around.
And then there's buildings on fire.
I can go in and save the person.
I can literally run into the building and save whoever's in that building.
And be a hero.
If somebody's drowning, they still drown.
They'll still fucking drown.
What can I do?
Watch them drown at a closer spot?
That's easy.
Fire also... okay we're not talking about the oxygen here.
Maybe they're like you know... what if they're just like in the...
I just like get like do like the movies because movies are so accurate.
I'll just get like a shirt and then like cover my my face like this.
And then I'll be fine.
The oxygen... the fire won't kill me.
I can breathe through my shirt.
Just like the movies.
Why would more people want to... what do you want to be?
Jesus?
Why the fuck would more people like want to walk on water?
They just want to be Jesus or something?
Oh my god.
I wouldn't be scared about like oil burns.
Because like that's like a mini fire.
What the fuck?
What are these questions?
This is just uncomfortable.
I feel like...
For like anybody this is just uncomfortable.
No!
No legit though.
That is... that is just incredibly uncomfortable.
Like why the fuck would you want that?
Like what if you're like... what if you're like having dinner with your parents?
Bro this would fucking... you know what?
Okay I'm actually curious.
I'm actually curious.
I know my answer.
Because like what is just incredibly uncomfortable in general.
Arouse versus no.
Okay.
Like what is chat... I want to know what is chat's answer to this.
One is just... no one is not just puberty.
Like cause like there's resting points.
I would assume that like you've rested.
There's like rest points.
Like there's no way.
This is always.
Like you would have... there's no resting.
It's just always.
What if you're at a funeral?
What if you're at a funeral chat?
What if you're at a fucking funeral?
And then you're... you have to like you know go see the fucking dead man.
And then you know people are gonna be like whoa.
Are you tell everybody at the funeral place?
Like at the funeral be like sorry I have a condition.
Where I'm always like you know.
So people be like oh my god.
That's auntie blah blah blah.
How could you?
Like are you telling everybody that?
So people won't be like whoa.
Why the fuck is go... what is going on?
Like...
I just won't go.
What if you're like at a will reading?
You have to do... in order to obtain whatever...
Okay that's not true.
You can actually... you don't need to...
You don't need to go to the will reading to like get what you want from the will.
But like you cannot...
You cannot always.
Like I don't understand why the poll is so close.
It should not be like 54%.
No there should be more of you guys who agree with me.
Like bros thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
It happens.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
Croak thank you for the super chat.
You can hide around some place at the time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
That guy seems to be talking with a lot of experience there.
Alright.
How is there... how did it fall down?
How did the fucking percentage fall down?
Alright.
I'm gonna go with two.
This is just not it.
I swear... why?
You can never fucking go near a pool ever again.
You can never go near playgrounds.
Ever again.
Or like live anywhere.
Like you can never like go anywhere.
That's... go anywhere.
It would be so bad for you.
So bad.
It's so bad.
Okay.
Alright.
Be an elder sibling.
Be a younger sibling.
I feel like younger is the best option.
Because I'm an only child.
I'm an... I'm an only child.
And like... and like I don't know what it's like to be either of these.
But from movies and TV shows.
You know because they're always accurate.
I feel like the eldest sibling is like...
The... the guinea pig.
You know?
Where they test out what works and what doesn't work.
And then like you know...
When they're like...
Oh shit.
That doesn't work.
I won't be doing that to the younger sibling.
So like...
Obviously all the...
If they try to do some stuff that clearly didn't work and cause trauma.
For the elder sibling.
The younger...
They learn that for the younger sibling.
They'll be like...
Oh...
Yeah it's like the older sibling would be like...
The trial run.
The test child.
And then the next one would be like...
Okay we realized what worked.
And what didn't work.
So we're gonna...
We're gonna like...
Try not to do that.
And then...
But you wanna be the youngest.
Because obviously...
They'll be like...
The second child.
Alright that didn't work.
They're like...
The second child is where you test out the theories to see if it was true.
So like...
Hahaha...
So...
So you test out the theories that you tried out on the eldest.
And then you try to be like...
Okay...
The middle child.
Middle child.
We're gonna try all these other theories.
And see what worked.
What is definitely working or not.
And then finally...
The third child is where they're like...
We perfected it.
The third child would be like...
Where you perfect the whole raising kids thing.
And was like...
We figured it out.
For real.
Hahaha...
So...
Middle child has to be the worst.
I feel like.
Cause then...
The eldest obviously...
You know...
They were born first.
And then the youngest...
They are like...
Ooh...
I'm gonna spoil you.
Cause you're the youngest now.
And...
So I would say youngest.
Also the reason why...
The younger sibling...
It's because like...
The older your siblings are...
The more likely they are to be the youngest.
The more likely they are gonna get married.
So when they get married.
They have to give you...
The unmarried person.
Red pocket money.
So then if you're the youngest...
The eldest has to give you money.
Cause they get married.
Just think of it that way.
True...
Not the red pocket.
Just think of it that way.
Cause you're the youngest.
Because the eldest will eventually have to get married.
I like how someone is like, girl I'm white.
This only applies to certain people.
I'm sorry.
Anyway, I feel like being the youngest sibling is the best option.
Let's see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can confirm.
As the eldest of six, oldest kid is the test drive model.
Youngest is pampered and spoiled.
Middle kids are normal.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gia!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As an elder sibling, you get to form the rules based on what works for you.
If you play your cards right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, I'm gonna be the younger sibling.
I didn't make a poll for this because I thought...
Oh my god!
It was a 50-50!
People who...
People who are on the fence were only...
were only challenged so they couldn't think as smart as I did.
Lose your sense of touch.
Lose your sense of sight.
I would lose my... No.
Oh my god.
This is actually...
This is difficult.
This is actually difficult.
No touch versus no sight.
I swear this song has been playing on repeat.
Like I'm going crazy right now.
Like...
This is... I swear.
This song has been playing for like 16 minutes.
I'm skipping this.
I was like, I swear I've been listening to this BGM for 16...
For like forever.
Oh my god.
Let's see.
Alright.
Lose your sense of touch or sight.
That's actually really difficult.
I don't know.
I'm thinking like what are like the benefits for either or.
Both of these are awful.
Yeah, they are all pretty fucking bad.
That's why I was like, I don't know.
They're all fucking terrible.
Oh.
Yeah.
They're all pretty fucking bad.
So it's such a difficult choice.
I feel like... okay.
No touch means you...
bang up your bod.
That's true.
No one believed this story when I first told it.
But like...
There's like this girl in the UK...
who doesn't feel anything.
She doesn't feel anything at all.
She's like a kid.
So like she doesn't feel anything at all.
So and then like the thing is...
You know, she gets hurt a lot.
She gets hurt a lot because... but she doesn't feel anything.
So she has... she's always like getting hurt and stuff, but she doesn't feel anything because she doesn't feel pain.
Oh my god, Jonathan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But like... but the thing... the good side about that is that she can survive getting hit by a car.
Because... okay.
It depends on like the speed of the car, but...
But there was a story with her.
She survived.
She didn't get injured from getting hit by a car.
Because she doesn't feel anything.
So she doesn't tense up because she has zero fear.
She has zero fear because she doesn't feel anything.
So...
She wouldn't... she got hit by a car and because she didn't tense up or anything and her muscles were like super relaxed.
Um, she didn't break anything.
She had no broken bones or anything.
I bet she got like... like her knees were scraped and stuff.
Her knees were scraped and everything.
So she...
So it was like... it was so fucking crazy.
And by the way, she got hit by a car in front of her family.
Like that's so...
Imagine being a family that watched that happen.
She like... with the... in front of like her mom and her siblings.
And she got hit by a car.
And they're like, oh my god.
And then she just got up and like walked up to her mom.
And was like, yay!
I was like, holy fuck.
That is trauma right there.
She got up after getting hit by a car.
Walked up to her mom.
It was like, yay.
It was like a fucking...
It was like a video interview about it.
And the mom... you could tell the mom was just...
You could tell the mom...
She's going through some stuff right now.
From that interview.
Um...
Potato, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No touch piece, no love life.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I feel like...
I don't know.
I guess like... I don't...
Do I really wanna... I don't know.
Like, I guess...
I don't know.
I feel like...
If I can't see, I can't play video games.
So...
I think like...
How...
How would I... How would I play video games?
Though...
So... I don't know.
I feel like...
I rather lose my sense of touch.
You can... Yeah, but like...
It's not... It's harder.
It's gonna...
It'll be so much harder.
To play video games.
I think I can live with no touch.
As a gamer, I need my eyes.
Guys, think of it this way.
I'm already lost enough...
With eyes.
How the fuck am I...
Now think...
What's gonna happen...
With no eyes.
If even with eyes...
And a map...
I get... I'm like directionless.
True.
I feel like that's even worse.
I'm gonna say...
Lose my sense of touch.
Yeah.
Yeah, no one chose that.
Thank God.
People who debated for like lose...
Okay.
Fast.
Why the f... Why?
Why would anyone pick this?
We're skipping.
Bro, who is the 15%?
What the fuck is wrong?
Like...
What the fuck is the...
Ring, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Who is the 50% that chose that?
Like what the... Are you okay?
That's all I can think.
Like are you okay?
Um...
Marry your crush...
But you will slowly become...
Oh my God.
Enemies to lovers.
The perfect trope.
Because like...
That's worse, you know?
Things you like... Like a person...
And then you slowly hate them more and more and more.
That's terrible.
I feel like...
Enemies to lovers.
Real!
But how slow is slowly?
How slow?
Like 90 years though?
Like on the diet... Like on the diet...
And you're like...
Bro...
I know we got married...
For like...
The green card... But bro...
I think...
I love you bro...
I think that's romantic.
It was just normal marriage.
Bro...
Okay.
We're gonna...
We're gonna go with this...
No poll.
This is too...
There's no way... Like yeah, why?
Like you're gonna eventually fall in love.
Be stuck outside...
All your... Be stuck... Okay that's just a pandemic...
That's just a pandemic.
We're already inside.
No poll for this.
No debate... Why?
Why?
Why would you want to be with nature?
How is... I don't understand.
The reason why we went outside is the reason why the pandemic lasted that long.
Like...
Like, what the fuck?
Alright.
Living forever...
versus...
10 more years.
Alright.
Forever... 10.
Oh, this is like such a... what's it called?
It's such a...
I guess like a philosophical-esque question.
Like there's no right or wrong for this.
Okay.
Honestly, I choose forever.
Okay, no, no.
Okay.
Okay, it depends.
It really depends.
Because like, I think like forever...
I feel like forever...
more so than 10 more years.
But forever is like pretty fucking rough.
I need... Okay, actually, no.
It depends on how this is gonna be.
Will I age along with forever?
Can I say young?
Because like...
What if like, you know, I'm like 350 years old?
And I am...
You look at me and you're like, yeah, she's 350 years old.
Like, I'm just thinking.
I won't be able to walk clearly at 350 years old.
I won't be able to eat for myself or use the...
I have to wear like fucking the elderly diapers and stuff like that.
Because you gotta admit when you're that old.
I don't think you can control much about your body.
So I'm just thinking.
I'm just thinking.
I don't want to be like...
I don't want to look like I'm 350.
I don't want...
So...
Also like...
I'm scared about like what the world's gonna be...
after 350 years later.
I'm a little scared.
So...
So I just think maybe 10 more years is better.
Because I'm worried about what are the conditions of forever.
Because like...
What happens when the sun explodes?
I don't know if you guys know this.
But like...
The sun is alive, technically.
Well, not really alive.
But like it will...
The sun will eventually die.
Because it's a giant ass star.
And like stars eventually die.
So...
Like...
When the sun explodes...
What's gonna happen to me?
How am I surviving that?
I can't breathe in...
I can't breathe in space.
Yes, eventually the sun will die.
And like what the fuck am I gonna do when the sun dies?
Like I'm just gonna float in space until I land on another planet?
Because I live forever.
Move elsewhere?
I guess like by the time the sun explodes we would have the technology to like move to another planet.
You live...
Hopefully no dimension.
That too, Jonathan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So I'm gonna choose 10 more...
There's too many variables I can't control.
But forever.
I don't know if I'm gonna be young forever.
I don't know if I'm gonna be young forever or I'm gonna be like...
The age of which I am forever of.
So...
So 10 more years.
I'm gonna pick 10 more years.
I feel like yeah.
I'm in the majority there.
Okay.
Have to walk on all fours.
Have to hop on one foot.
What if you just don't go anywhere?
I feel like you trip more with this though.
I feel like...
I don't wanna make a poll for this.
You...
There's more chances to trip more.
But then you look so...
Okay.
You...
Both of these options you look so fucking stupid.
Like...
No matter what.
Both of these options you look so fucking stupid.
Yes.
But then your hands gonna touch like...
Unless you wear hand shoes.
I guess like...
By then...
I'll invest in hand shoes though.
So like...
My hands won't be like...
Touching like...
The gross stuff.
But...
Oh my god.
Well...
You walking.
What if you drive?
Good...
Good question.
This says walk.
It doesn't say gloves.
Oh sorry.
Gloves.
My hand shoes.
Sorry.
In other words...
Gloves.
That's what I meant.
I can just wear gloves.
So I won't have to like...
Oh my gosh.
This is difficult.
But if I never...
That's so difficult.
Because it's like...
What if like...
Okay.
Like...
Here's what I'm thinking.
What if I like go to a buffet?
I have to walk to a thing.
Where do...
And then we have to walk back to the buffet area.
Like...
It doesn't work for me.
I guess I'll have someone else to hold my tray.
Because like...
How the fuck am I gonna...
Like...
How am I going to fucking...
I'll just never be able to go to buffets anymore.
Hold the plate in your mouth.
I'll never be able to do buffets anymore.
I don't...
Just don't go...
Doki.
There's a very simple answer to this.
Just don't go to the buffet.
But what if I want to go to the buffet?
I don't want to.
I'd like to have the choice of being able to go to the buffet.
I want to have...
It's like...
Okay.
You know...
Like I would never do this.
But I'd like to have the choice to do it.
Like...
I would not want to commit murder.
But I would...
If the choice comes...
You know...
It's sort of relatable.
It's sort of something you can compare.
Anyway.
I think I'd choose...
I feel like...
I feel like hopping on one foot causes more accidents.
Over like...
Walking all fours wherever you go.
So I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go with all fours.
Anyway.
I'm gonna go with all fours, guys.
Alright.
There's more people with hopping on...
Why?
Guys.
Who wants to hop on one foot?
Give me your why.
I need you guys to explain your reasons.
Who is like the normies?
Who are the normies here?
Who's the normies?
Why would you want to hop on one foot?
Over like...
On...
Using all fours.
All fours is the furry answer.
I hate no furry.
Okay.
I need you guys to explain your reasons for not hopping on one foot.
Win the lottery but lose all your friends.
I mean that's basically what actually happens.
Remain broke but keep your friends.
Okay.
Just don't...
But like...
People on the Internet won't know that...
You can't make Internet friends as well.
Like...
Where does this go?
So two and...
No.
Where is my phone?
Okay.
No friends, but money vs.
no money friends.
Okay.
Money.
No friends.
Friends.
Yeah, like, can I just make new friends?
Yeah, I'll just make new friends.
I'm just saying, like...
I mean, winning the... also, I like how dated this is because winning the lottery doesn't even mean you...
like, a golden ticket anymore because of taxes.
Apparently, a lot of, like, lottery winners don't know, especially, like, if they're, like, they come from, like, not a lot of money.
They think winning the lottery immediately, automatically means you have money forever.
And a lot of lottery winners do not know that when you win the lottery, a lot of that money...
Like, it was like...
This is like a 1 million jackpot.
A lot of that money is just gonna be gone from taxes.
So, mostly, you... yeah, taxes take, like, 60% of the million.
And then you're left with, I don't know, like, 60% of that.
And then after... but then they'll be like, oh, I'm gonna quit my job.
And, like, my entire family is gonna sustain with, uh...
I'm...
Our entire lottery is gonna sustain with just the winnings.
And then they end up using all their money after, like, five years.
And then... and then they're broke again.
And then they're broke.
And... and then they go back.
They have to fucking get a job again.
Or... or another thing that happens is that a lot of people don't want their names...
Don't want their names to be public.
To be public in winning the lottery.
Because after winning the lottery, you have to...
A lot of your family and friends and relatives will try to contact you to be like, Oh my god, congratulations!
Can I borrow some of that money?
And then apparently... apparently a lot of them try to stay anonymous and stuff.
Because they don't want, like... they don't want that to happen to them.
And at one point, like, I don't know...
I read, like...
An article that one family, like, the parents got divorced and stuff.
And they're like, the lottery ruined our lives!
It ruined our lives!
I wish I would never won the lottery!
I read there was, like, one guy that won the lottery.
And he came over to pick it up with, like, with a mask on.
And he never told his family that he won.
He just, like, kept it in, like, some trust or something.
He was like, yeah, I'm not telling anybody.
That's so smart!
So, like, it's like an emergency fund.
Like, he just kept doing his job.
He just, like, kept working the same job.
Pretending that he never won the lottery.
I think he, like, wore a gorilla mask or some shit.
Yeah, a lot of divorces happen and stuff, too.
Because of the lottery.
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Apparently, winning the lottery in Canada needs you to do a math problem to receive the money.
So, option one is not viable for Doki.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Good, thank you for the super chat!
Canadian lottery winnings aren't ta- Oh my god, that's so nice.
That's so fucking nice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
I feel like people don't talk about the lottery anymore.
A lot of things, people don't talk a lot anymore.
I'm surprised people still watch TV.
That people still have, like, cable packages.
I'm pretty sure, like, the people who still watch TV, or, like...
I'm sorry, any dragoons that are still watching TV, I am so sorry.
I don't mean you guys, of course.
If you're a dragoon that still watches TV and, like, television, I don't mean you guys.
I meant the other people.
I... no, no, no, don't feel attacked.
I don't mean you guys.
I mean the other people.
That's not you.
Anyway, as I was...
As I was saying, I... I'm surprised, like...
Like, television networks are still making money off of, like, cable packages.
Off of cable in general.
And...
I don't... I never... I haven't had... I haven't watched TV in so fucking long.
Honestly, ever since, like, the piece... like...
Ever since streaming services was invented, I've just never watched TV again.
Uh...
Affiliate, I think about 10 gift-a-ships.
Thank you, thank you!
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
Breezy!
But if I win, I can give more money to...
Exactly, Breezy!
I'm your trust system.
I'm your bank.
We were branded.
Um, if you were part of the old bank, do not worry.
We've just reba... re... rebranded.
It's the Doki Bank now.
Um, same... same interest rates.
Your accounts are still here, by the way.
The Doki Bank account is still here.
Uh...
Your bank accounts are still safe.
The bank of Doki is still very safe.
Very good loans.
Very good interest rates.
So, just... if you ever win the lottery, just open an account in the bank of Doki.
Um, anyway...
I'd rather win the lottery, but lose all my friends.
What?
Really?
Why would you want to be broke?
It's not fun!
It's like... people say remain broke, but keep all my friends.
They've never been poor before.
Like...
What the...
Thank you, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Here's my deposit!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Like...
Like, I'm just saying...
I don't think they understand what the concept of being broke is.
Yeah...
I...
Like...
I'm just thinking...
I don't think they understand, like...
Like, what broke really is.
I think they're just like, oh, that's just me.
Yeah...
Um...
Alright.
Get piercings everywhere possible.
Tongue... I...
Well, I can like, remove the piercings, right?
Alright.
Let's see...
They say broke while still eating food.
Like, I'm just saying, like, when you're broke, you can't afford, like...
Like, you can't...
You have to like, be really strategic on how the fuck...
Like...
On how to survive day to day.
Um...
Okay.
Let's see.
Piercings...
Versus tattoos.
Tattoos...
But if your friend is a million...
Thank you for the super chat, JP.
Thank you.
I mean, if you're already broke...
And you're saying your friends are really a millionaire...
But you're still broke...
Like, it's the same problem.
Like...
Your friend...
Like, I'm just saying...
Like...
It's...
Then you wouldn't be broke.
You're like, my friend's a millionaire, but you still have the same problem about being broke.
You're still...
Then you still have that problem.
Um...
Anyway...
I would say...
Okay.
I don't know...
The thing is...
But like...
Does the head count as the tattoos?
I don't know.
Cause if it's just like the rest of my body, but not the head...
So then I could just cover it up for...
Like, if I have a real job that's not streaming...
And like, I have to go to the office and I have to cover everything up...
I guess like...
Is the head...
Okay.
But tattoos on the head?
On the face?
I don't know.
Face tattoos?
From...
I...
In my...
This is my personal opinion.
Face tattoos?
Just not it.
Like...
I just...
Just not it.
Face tattoos.
Just...
This is my own opinion.
But yeah.
Face tattoos?
Just not hitting it for me.
I feel like...
I don't know.
I just find face tattoos just...
Yeah.
Like, for piercings?
I can at least remove the piercings.
Right?
The piercings.
And then I can just remove it later.
So it's not...
Like...
It's just like places you can pierce.
This is all pretty bad.
I don't think I can get like a normal job.
Like...
Like, thinking about it, I'm just like, I can definitely not get a normal job.
In either of these scenarios.
Like...
Um...
Oh...
And like, my skin can heal.
Right?
Like, it doesn't mean I have to keep my piercings.
It's like when you get your ears pierced.
And then it heals.
In the end.
Right?
So like...
I feel like, you know, I could just get these piercings once.
And then the skin will just heal later on.
If I don't like keep it going.
That's just cheating.
It doesn't!
There was no...
What do you mean?
It's not cheating because it's not a problem.
It literally doesn't tell me the terms and conditions.
I make up the terms and conditions.
Here.
Um...
Does she know?
Wait, what do you mean if I know?
You...
You would...
What the fuck?
Tattoo isn't permanent?
Yes, they are!
What do you mean?
These are like...
Unless you're talking about like temporary tattoos.
Like the ones...
Do you know there's like a way you can like...
Okay, I've been...
Alright.
This is like...
You know what I mean?
There's like a guilty pleasure YouTube short channel that I've been watching.
But the...
The...
The Victor channel.
There's like a YouTube short channel where it is some guy cosplay...
Pretending as Victor from Despicable Me.
And he does these like internet...
Like proving internet videos if they're real or not.
And...
He's like...
And like...
There was one...
He was doing a short...
Yeah, that guy.
He was doing a short of like...
Of like those like...
There's like a machine where you can print temporary tattoos on your body.
And...
Like...
There was like...
And you just like...
You just like...
Like what was it?
You just put the data of what you want to print.
Yeah, it's a tattoo print.
That guy.
Yeah, I was like that's so fucking cool.
You can literally like print tattoos now on your skin.
Like temporary tattoos on your skin.
You don't have to do that whole like wetting the paper...
Put...
Like getting a temporary tattoo paper.
Wetting it.
And then put it on your skin.
And then like...
Like hold it on for a while.
There's literally a machine that can just print tattoos on your skin.
Print temporary tattoos.
Any temporary tattoo you want to.
I thought that was so fucking sick.
Um...
Anyway...
Uh...
I don't...
I don't know.
Does that include the eyes too?
You know like there's people that tattoo their eyes?
People are so fucking weird now.
Like...
You know like when technology advances more and more.
People are like...
Oh my god.
But what if I do this now?
Like...
Oh my god.
Technology.
It is advancing.
What if I tattoo my eye?
Anyway there was an article where some lady tattooed her eye and she went blind because of infection.
Like why?
You can change...
You can tattoo your eye to change the color of your eyes.
Just fucking wear contacts.
Like holy shit.
Like...
Just...
Some...
Some girl fucking tattooed her eye so she could change the color of her eye.
Just wear contacts.
There's colored contacts.
Anyway...
She went...
She went blind because...
Uh...
Because she fucking...
They got an infection.
Uh...
Um...
Alright.
Uh...
Breezy.
I'm gonna acknowledge your super chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Maria.
I don't want the piercing in the...
Nope.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Ah!
I guess...
I guess I'll go with tattoo.
I feel...
Oh my gosh.
But pain wise...
Okay.
They're pain wise.
They're both painful too.
Cause like...
There's like parts of your body for tattoos that's like super painful to get.
Oh my...
They're so terrible.
They're both such terrible.
Two things to pick from.
I guess I'll go...
I guess I'll go tattoos.
I'll just never go outside.
I'll just...
I guess I'll get tattoos and I'll also be on Ripley's Believe It or Not and the Guinness Book of Records.
I'll just do that.
There's like people who get like...
Oh my gosh.
The body modification stuff is actually wild.
It's fucking wild now.
Like I remember back then...
Cause back then as a little dokey I would collect like Ripley's Believe It or Not and like Guinness Book of Records and stuff like that.
And like there was some fucking wild shit where people would get like...
Yeah.
Lizard man.
There was like lizard man and like that guy that had like the whole skull thing.
You know?
Like the...
The...
He tattooed himself so that he looked like some fucking skull kid or whatever.
And there...
I'm just like thinking like you can get some...
There's like uh one person who tried to get plastic surgery to look like a Ken doll or a Barbie girl.
And like it's fucking...
Oh my god is this the same song?
I swear to god.
Am I list...
It's the same one.
Why does it keep going?
I don't know.
We are going back to this.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm not gonna do shuffle anymore.
It keeps going back to that one song.
Oh my god, we're gonna go crazy here.
Alright.
Anyway.
Um...
I know like people have been doing some fucking...
weird ass body modifications.
Alright.
Return every non-essential item you've ever bought.
Never be able to buy anything non-essential again.
Wait.
That just means like I'll... That's just this but worse.
Isn't that just this but worse?
Like I have to return everything, right?
But does that mean I can buy more?
Oh, then get it back.
Oh, okay.
Then I can just buy it back.
Then that's fine.
Like non-essential items?
I can't buy toilet... Wait.
Is toilet paper considered non-essential?
Right?
Cause like you don't really need toilet paper.
You can just get like a bidet.
That's... That's the... I guess like...
You can just use the shower like...
Like...
Let's see.
Essential if no bidet.
Bidet is better.
Um.
I remember there was like the South Park episode where like the toilet paper comp...
Cause like...
NA is like one of the only...
places where bidet is not common.
But bidet is actually healthier for your skin as well.
Cause like the paper...
The toilet paper like actually is not good for your skin and stuff.
Like bidet is actually better.
But the fucking toilet paper companies...
I'm pretty sure the toilet paper company just has a huge monopoly.
Yeah.
No.
It's true.
If you use like dry toilet paper...
It's actually worse for your skin.
And like you have to use like baby wipes or... Cause like you have to... The paper has to be wet.
It's actually really bad for your butt.
Like...
I'll just... I'll just say that.
Toilet paper is actually pretty bad for your butt.
So... So... Um...
It's actually better to use like bidets or like baby wipes.
But baby wipes is also really bad.
For... I think like... I think like they say like baby wipes is really bad for...
Um... The pipes and stuff.
Uh... But yeah.
Like it's actually healthier to use a bidet.
Um... And... And I just wish bidets were popular... More popular.
In NA.
I just wish bidets were more popular in NA.
I miss bidets so much ever since like you know when you go to Japan.
And you have a bidet.
And then you go back.
And then you're like...
I feel like a caveman.
I... I fucking feel like a caveman every time I come back.
Like... Yeah.
Do not flush baby wipes.
It's very bad for your pipes.
By the way.
It... It's... It's very bad.
Um...
Um... But yeah.
I just... God.
I'm gonna say this one.
I'm not gonna make a pose for this.
Because I feel like...
That's so fucked up if I can't buy anything non-essential again.
Break into a stranger's home and stay for two days without them knowing.
Stay... Why the fuck would... Why?
Why would I go outside?
Bro.
I'm not gonna debate about this.
This is terrible.
They won't know.
Like...
It's like I was never there.
Exactly.
They won't know.
I just leave after two days.
After they... They won't know.
Literally break into a mansion.
Stay at Bill Gates' mansion.
He has so many.
He wouldn't care.
He has so many fucking vacation homes.
I literally break into one of Bill Gates' vacation homes.
Stay there for two days.
And then leave.
How would they know?
Not even need a poll.
I don't need a vote for this.
Alright.
What the fuck we want...
These people just love nature.
Drink hot drinks in summer.
Drink cold drinks.
Not gonna debate.
I already do this anyway.
Um...
Like I don't care.
Hot drinks in summer feels so much worse than cold drinks in winter.
Um...
I just choose cold drinks in winter.
I feel like this is fucking terrible.
I could be inside and drink cold drinks.
Tell your best friend all your secrets.
Tell your parents all...
Oh...
I dare them to weaponize it.
That is difficult.
That is actually difficult.
Parents...
Secret...
Okay...
Best...
Friend...
Secrets...
Versus...
Parents...
Best...
Friend...
Parents...
Both suck.
They do.
Okay.
Ah...
Alright.
I feel...
Parents...
Best...
Friend...
Okay.
Wait.
Tom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, he lives in a Bill-gated community.
You'll never get in.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I could be Bill Gates like...
Like...
Don...
Lost...
Like...
Cousin...
Five times removed.
You don't know that.
You don't know my genetics.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I feel like...
Parents...
Because I feel like...
Wait.
If you...
If you tell your best friend...
All your secrets...
And then they're no longer your best friend...
You're fucked.
You're so fucked.
Like...
Cause like...
You can lose friends...
Much more...
Much more easily...
Than parents.
Like...
I feel like...
You can...
You know...
I mean...
For parents...
You could be like...
Um...
What's that word?
Excommunicated from your parents.
But like...
There's a higher chance...
That you're...
You would lose your best friend...
Over...
Like...
Being ex...
Getting kicked out by your parents.
Someone's like...
You're Asian!
What does that matter?
Even if I get like...
Disowned...
From my parents...
It's less likely...
Um...
It's less likely to happen...
Versus getting...
Like...
Losing your best friend.
It's easier to lose friends...
Than to be disowned.
Like...
What if I tell like...
The best friend...
Something so fucked up...
That they're like...
I can't be your best friend anymore.
And then they tell people about that fucked up secret.
Like...
If I tell my parents...
Okay...
Something super fucked up...
It was like...
I murdered my parents.
They'll be like...
I didn't...
How do we hide the body?
You could be like...
But best friends will do that too.
Best friends will...
You could say...
Best friends...
Will help you hide the body.
But will they really?
Will they...
Would...
It's so easy to say that.
It's so easy for a friend who's not related to you say that.
But will they really do it?
The thing is, they can...
They don't have to hide the body, because they'll be like...
Well, if I just pretend I never knew you.
I won't be involved.
But the parents wise...
Parents, if you kill somebody, they need to help you.
Because their reputation is connected to you.
Because they don't want to be the parents of the daughter who committed murder.
Like...
They...
Their reputation is on the line.
Because they'll also be in the articles too.
They'll be like, oh my god, how could this parent raise a monster who murdered like five people.
So they have to hide the body for you.
Because they don't want that to be on the line.
But then your best friend, if you kill somebody, they'll be like, holy fuck, I'm gonna call the police because I don't wanna be like...
Because they'll have to go to trial.
They'll have to go to trial.
And like, they'll have to go to jail for being involved.
And they're not even related to me.
Why would they want to hide the body?
They're not related to me.
They cannot even have to...
They won't have to be in trial for anything.
Or like, be involved.
Or go to jail.
And everything.
So...
I'll tell the parents.
You guys would tell your best friend?
All your secrets?
Like, really?
Why would you guys tell your best friend over your parents?
I feel like you might have a secret.
Like, if you're like...
It's like all your secrets.
You can't all be fucking clean.
Like...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One of my best friend is a pig.
Pigs are perfect for hiding a body.
They would just eat it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I trust your friend.
Do you... Okay.
You can't be fully clean.
Come on.
I got no secrets that would send me to jail.
Okay.
I'm just saying.
Because I don't want my parents to know what I watch at night.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I have no enemies.
I mean...
My friend won't judge me as much.
I guess you could say that.
Your friend won't judge.
But then, what if you're not friends anymore?
I'm not friends anymore.
What if you're not friends anymore?
And they know all of that.
My friend...
I like how someone's like, don't worry.
My friend has done way worse stuff than me.
So I'm fine with that.
If my parents knew everything, I would disappear.
Okay.
Unimportant.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I changed my mind.
If I had friends, they would probably be as weird as me.
My parents said they would go to the police.
You don't know that.
It's all like...
You know deep down, your parents do not want to be the parents of a son or daughter that murdered somebody.
They say that.
But you know deep down, they don't want to be in the article as the parent that raised a monster.
They don't want to be in the article as the parent that raised a monster.
They don't...
My dad is a cop.
Mercy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As long as you know what felonies your friends have committed, you'll always part ways.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My parents were in it with pride.
Okay.
I guess I was like, my parents are very good at avoiding accountability.
They'll still be in the end.
They'll be fucking in the articles being like, these are the parents that raised a child who murdered five people in five different states.
They'll still be in the article.
They will be like, that's the best friend.
No one cares about that's the best friend who was the friend of the murderer that murdered five people in five different states.
No one would say that.
Everyone would always mention the parents.
Is this a good...
No, guys, it's all figuratively.
It's like, what if I did he he like, you know, what if I did murder five people in five different states?
He he.
Michael, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What if I told my best friend my darkest secret?
They'd call me basic.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I would tell my parents all my secrets.
I do that.
It's all hypothetical situation.
This is all hypothetical.
Really?
I'm the 35%?
You guys...
You guys just don't understand me.
All right.
Always have a random taste in your mouth or be unable to have taste in your mouth.
Oh, they all suck.
I hate either of these options.
I hate either of these.
They all fucking suck.
I feel like, damn, Dragoons be busy with all these murders.
Marth, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
I don't know if I want my parents to find out how much I spent on...
Is that a secret?
How is that deep dark secret, Darkblade?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, one is always... Oh my God.
Why are you ashamed?
Darkblade, how dare you?
How could you be ashamed, Darkblade?
I don't know.
They're all terrible.
I don't like either of them.
I feel I'm not gonna make a poll for this one, but I feel like...
I guess... I guess I'll like get used to it.
It could be a random good taste.
Yeah, it's gotcha.
You know, life is wild.
Life is fucking wild.
It's like gotcha.
Alright.
Face a zombie apocalypse or face a robot?
Okay, this one's interesting.
Zombies versus robots.
Zombies.
Robots.
I'd say like...
I'd say one.
I'd say zombies.
Alright, fanfiction already have no taste.
Tom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'd say zombies over robots.
Because robots, you can't use any technology ever again.
Because robots would just like use it.
You know, like robots will like take over all sense of...
It's just Y2K.
It's literally what if Y2K happened and the robots just take over the world.
And like I feel like robots having that much power is a lot worse than zombies.
Because zombies are brainless in the end.
And they're easier to kill.
Robots!
You can shoot your gun at a robot.
It doesn't mean they're fucking dead.
You have to like fry their circuits or something.
Or like Skynet.
Yeah, it's like Skynet and Y2K.
And honestly, what if the robots are hot?
If evil, why hot?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There can be hot zombies.
What happened to that warm bodies?
Remember that fucking zombie...
Zombie...
Romantic movie about like having a zombie boyfriend?
Like...
They can both be hot.
What?
Warm bodies!
That was a thing?
Warm bodies was a thing?
People wanted to fuck the zombie boyfriend.
I saw it.
It was on Tumblr.
People are so obsessed with the zombie boyfriend thing.
Anyway.
I would say...
Also Chris, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A true dragoon always sacrifices their wad for the greater good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I would say... I would definitely say zombie apocalypse.
I feel like... Okay.
A robot apocalypse eventually... They can... Okay.
The thing is...
A robot apocalypse... They can just rebuild more robots.
That's the thing.
Like that's endless.
Zombies!
They just need to turn other people to zombies.
So like...
By then, you can find a...
You can find a cure for the zombie apocalypse.
I don't think you can find a cure for a robot apocalypse.
It's more endless.
Because they can just rebuild themselves.
Zombies can make more zombies but they require bodies.
They require bodies.
Um...
But like a robot apocalypse...
They'll just keep building robots.
There's more of a chance...
You can say EMP.
But like...
What if you...
There's always a possibility that...
That like a robot apocalypse will come back.
Like you can never trust technology again.
I don't like that.
I want to be able to use the internet while I'm in apocalypse.
Oh my god.
Think of the YouTube content you can get.
Haha.
Day 55.
On the search for supplies.
Like...
Okay...
I feel like...
If we had a zombie apocalypse now...
In the current day...
There's going to be YouTube tutorials of people like...
Giving like YouTube tutorials on like how to survive zombie apocalypse.
Assuming that the internet still works.
I'm just thinking, you know, like the YouTube headquarters with all the servers, with all the internet servers and stuff for YouTube.
Like, what are the zombies gonna do?
They're not gonna destroy the servers.
They're fucking brainless.
All they wanna do is just eat other people.
So, like, the servers are gonna be safe.
It just needs to be powered up, you know?
Like, the YouTube servers and, like, you know, we already have the experience.
We have the experience with, like, the pandemic.
So, we can work at home.
We don't have to be at the office to work on the YouTube servers.
So, then we can...
How would they destroy electricity?
They don't have fucking any neural neuron, like...
Neurological, like, craving to destroy the electricity.
Who's maintaining the power grid?
I don't know.
Just build a fucking fort around the power grid.
I feel like you can be, like, really rich in supplies if you're...
People who can't live without the internet...
Will give so much supplies to the person who runs the power grid.
Like...
They'll be like, here is my...
They'll be, like, treated like gods.
It's like, what's it called?
What's that movie called?
Mad Max?
It's like that guy that owned the water tower.
The person who owns the internet...
Will be treated like a god.
Just like that guy.
HAHAHAHAHAHA HAHAHAHAHAHA HAHAHAHAHAHA Yeah, yeah.
Internet Joe.
HAHAHAHAHAHA They'll be like...
Internet Joe, please.
I need my content.
Can you... Here's my...
Here's my food supply.
For the next two weeks.
If you keep the internet alive.
I don't know how to make...
I don't know how to make a...
I don't know how to make a desk.
We need desks in our...
In our bunker.
And we don't know...
And we need the YouTube video tutorial on how to make a desk.
Please, Internet Joe.
Here...
HAHAHAHAHAHA You shall reach YouTube Chrome and shine.
HAHAHAHAHAHA Okay.
Okay.
I stream.
I die.
I stream again.
Exactly!
Guys, look.
We need our YouTube tutorials chat.
Joe, I'm...
Joe, please help us.
Please.
Give sector...
Sector F...
Um...
Fiber.
We cannot...
We cannot live...
With...
With 10 ups...
HAHAHAHA 10...
10 upload speed.
Please help us.
Give us at least 50...
50...
50 uploads and download speed.
Please, Internet Joe.
HAHAHAHAHAHA
Let's see.
Um...
Mr. Moose, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Zombie apocalypse.
I guarantee the IRS has a contingency plan for collecting taxes during a zombie apocalypse.
I...
Joe, please.
I can never go back to 10.
Joe.
Hmm...
Ok...
Oh, guys.
Varsan!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you!
You all saw the Hell divers...
Look, the robots are really scary...
The robots were really fucking scary...
I am going to go with zombie apocalypse.
All right...
Nice.
All right.
Act...
This is stupid.
I am going to go with movies and TVs.
This is too much work.
Broadway is way too much work.
Like, this...
Filmed...
Done.
This is too much.
Also, you don't... you're not really famous when you're a Broadway star.
Always be lonely?
This is so sad.
Bro, this is too much.
But this is also so sad.
This is... bro, I don't wanna answer this.
As an introvert, this is way too much as an introvert.
But this is way too little.
I'm not gonna debate about this.
I'm gonna stay surrounded by others.
Cause then I can always have collabs.
Doki, stop thinking about the content!
But then like, I can always have like, collabs if I want.
It'll be easier to afford to get collabs.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna do like two more questions.
Chat, I'm gonna do two more than one.
We'll call it here.
The streamer mindset.
Alright.
Video game versus movie.
Video game... movie.
I say video game?
Okay, it depends if I'm the main character.
Because I can have respawn.
I can respawn.
And the favorite... I feel like... I feel like video game.
It depends on what video game it is, so...
It depends on what video game.
But I feel like if I was in my favorite video game, I can always respawn.
Oh wait, my favorite is like Professor Layden.
So like, I'm fine.
I can be Luke!
Luke, my boy!
Professor!
Yeah, I'm gonna do...
My favorite movie?
I don't even know what my favorite movie is.
Professor!
Alright, I'll say video game.
I don't even know... I don't think I have a favorite movie.
I don't think so.
So I'm gonna go with video game.
This is not really a debate.
What?
I guess... normies.
Fucking normies.
Hahahaha!
Alright, I'm refreshing.
This question sucks.
This is not gonna be my last question.
I'm refreshing this.
This is a bad would you rather.
Alright.
Uh...
I'm gonna try and get a good one.
Uhhhh...
Let's see.
Oh my god!
This was terrible!
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I'm gonna...
That's not gonna be my...
Hahaha!
I can't get it!
We're ending it with this.
This is like debate club.
We're gonna end it with this one.
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
We're gonna end it with this one.
Alright.
Okay.
This is so easy for me.
But...
No matter what choice we make, we're all horrible people.
Cause like...
Hahaha!
Cause like a lot of people are like, cancer!
But then someone's like, bro, where did you get cancer?
World hunger kills more people.
But like...
But...
Okay!
But cancer!
But if we cure cancer!
My mom can't be like, this food can cause cancer anymore.
She can't...
My parents can't lie and be like, don't do this, it'll cause cancer.
Don't do that, it'll cause cancer.
If I cure cancer, that won't be an excuse anymore!
Hahaha!
Cause someone's like, I'd rather save kids than adults.
Cancer patients get hungry too.
Well, they're already suffering through many things!
At least we'll get rid of one...
Okay, if we starve...
You can't say...
Cancer patients are already starving too.
Because they'll die from one or the other.
Like...
We say, cure world hunger.
But they're still gonna fucking suffer from cancer!
Like, what kind of fucking question is that?
What kind of fucking answer is that?
Eventually, we will solve...
Look, you don't cure world hunger.
You just...
You don't cure world hunger.
It's just that...
It's just that we don't provide...
We don't have...
Like, we don't provide food to like...
Like, we are not good at providing food to people, apparently.
Hahaha!
Cause there's already a cure to world hunger!
And it's just food!
Yeah!
It's literally just food!
There's no cure!
We have the cure!
We're just not applying the cure!
Hahaha!
Um...
Charles...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cancer is harder.
World hunger is more of a dis...
Yeah, exactly!
It's a distribution issue!
We have the cure!
And it's just food!
But we don't provide the food!
We don't provide...
We don't distribute the food!
We don't know what the cure is!
We don't have the evidence for cancer yet!
I'm so right.
We're always being like, we are in a new breakthrough regarding the cure for cancer.
But we still haven't fucking cured cancer yet.
Um...
World hunger gone, equals lesser crime, equals lesser death.
But cancer is terrible!
Okay.
Anyway.
Hahaha!
Meanwhile, us wasting...
Okay!
Okay, I feel like some of that part is so fucked up, but like there's literally nothing we can do about it.
The wasting food part, because it's like there's a lot of like supermarkets and a lot of bakeries and a lot of like food making places.
Where if there's like an excess amount of food, they don't donate the food, they just throw it out.
Because it's a legal issue.
Because what if somebody gets sick off of the food you donated, they have the legal means to sue you.
And like in America, everybody loves to sue people.
Like everyone loves to pursue lawsuits.
So people don't... they are like we have to throw it away because they don't want to be liable to...
They don't want to be liable to be...
They don't want to be liable for it too.
I know that's like one of the reasons.
I don't know what the other reasons were as to why they don't donate the food.
But I don't remember why... there was like another reason why they don't donate the food.
But it's like this is like one of the main reasons because they don't want to be liable for a lawsuit if somebody gets sick off of the food you donated.
If you give it to a food bank, then you waive all the...
liability.
That's a myth?
Oh my god!
I believed that for so long!
It's like the whole McDonald's thing all over again.
They can write off the losses.
Oh, it's all about taxes, man.
It's always...
Why does this always come back to taxes?
Why does this always come back to taxes, man?
It's just like the McDonald's coffee thing all over again.
Where they fucking tell you that was true and then you finalist.
Did you guys know?
Super Size Me?
Apparently, we were lied to about the movie Super Size Me.
Because apparently, the guy who made that movie, who made Super Size Me, embellished it so much that like apparently, like, a lot of the people who made it, they were like, oh, this is so good.
But the movies from Super Size Me is a fucking lie.
I watched that movie in class at least four times.
It was terrible.
I fucking watched Super Size Me at least three to four times because our teachers were always like, let's watch something educational.
Super Size Me regarding like the health and the fast food industry.
What Super Size Me is about some dude that fucking binged himself with McDonald's and got like incredibly unhealthy.
Yeah.
His wife divorced him after.
I shouldn't laugh about this, but like it's because I don't know if it's his wife or his girlfriend, but like his girlfriend's vegan.
It's either like his girlfriend or his wife, but like his girlfriend or wife like left him because like she's vegan and then she could never stop eating.
And he was also like vegetarian slash vegan.
I don't remember which one.
He was apparently like vegan slash vegetarian.
And he did the whole Super Size Me stuff.
And and then like and then like he couldn't go back.
He couldn't stop eating meat.
Like he couldn't stop.
And then also like he was complaining.
About like the health issues.
But also he was a full on vegan and you cannot go straight into fast food after being vegan for so long.
Like your body is not fucking your body cannot handle that.
If you used to be vegan and you suddenly decided to just eat fast food.
Like.
There's like shit like that.
Anyway, Super Size Me was apparently a fucking lie.
I couldn't believe it when I when I found out it like broke my world.
It actually like ruined reality for me because I I was like I saw that movie so many times at school and then people were like, by the way, Super Size Me was so embellished.
Hey.
Anyway, anyway, anyway, a super size though.
I think the super size though, like for those who didn't know McDonald's used to used to like have a size called Super Size and it was like fucking crazy.
I still I do think the super size size amount is insane.
So like I would give them that like I would fucking give them that regarding super size.
Like.
And an American portion is so funny.
I was watching a short about like fast food portions and it was like it was like like here are American fast food portions versus like Asia fast food portions.
And I'm like, Jesus fucking Christ.
Like I think it was like Japan large was like an American like medium or something.
And I was like, Jesus fucking Christ.
I'm just like, bro, what the fuck, bro?
Like the soda cups are just crazy.
And anyway, I cure cancer.
It's a rough decision.
I think I think this is like a good a good place to end it.
Cancer.
The world.
The fucking hardest, hardest talk we had to have.
I like how I like how ended it with that.
Oh, my God.
It was we did it.
We cured cancer.
Dragoons.
We figured it out.
Anyway, guys, OK, anyway, as I had a great time just hanging out with all of you.
It was I had a fun time debating and hanging out with all of you guys today.
It was very fun.
It was really enjoyable.
I knew we could do it no matter what.
We can be both terrible and good people as well because we cured one thing.
Anyway, that was wild.
We had a wild time today chat.
But I honestly always enjoy streaming for you guys, and I always enjoy like having these random fucking discussions with both with both of you, with all two of you, Dragoons.
One will debate about the other and then one will debate about that.
With both two of you, Dragoons.
It was so fun.
One of them is you.
That's you.
That's right.
I'm talking about you.
You.
She's talking about me.
Yes.
You.
We're both two Dragoons.
Anyway.
I'm going to call it here, everybody.
I hope you guys had fun hanging out with me today.
As always, everyone stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.